did you ever follow up with the Matthew
McConaughey after the the Ralphie May
yeah he never said anything you never
saw him no that was just in the backyard
have you ever heard this song oh my god
when Ralphie first moved to a lot of
people don't know like when you moved to
an old Hollywood neighborhood you'll see
a celebrity in that neighborhood
and you go why is that person here well
because they lived in that neighbor
before they made it and now they're
going to visit their friends and that
neighborhood it was the chick from the
wrestler
my cousin Vinnie oh North Marissa
tomei's sister lived on that block so
you would see her walk with her dogs all
the time and this is a shitty part of
Hollywood
Guns and Roses had a garage across the
street that's where they lived so it was
by the Guitar Center right there
and there's a big garage uh behind where
Matthew McConaughey uh we're [__] uh
what Marissa told my sister lives and
that's where Matthew used to have his
cars when he was broke
they're broken down garages and he had
like a Volkswagen you know those
two-door Volkswagens yeah with the trunk
in the front he had one of those and no
not a beetle the the rabbit the rat like
not the rabbit the square one but the
longer one it doesn't matter anyway he
had one of those in his in his garage
and he would come back there and work on
them
I didn't know this I didn't even know
there was garages back there but Ralphie
lived on
Schrader
back in that neighborhood that
neighborhood was Josh Wolf on Vista
Ralphie was on Schrader
Nick depaolo and Mitch Hedberg were on
Sierra Bonita and Doug Stanhope was on
Curson wow this is a hell of a [__]
neighborhood yeah and we'd all played
tennis at three o'clock down by Gorky
Park a Russian Park on yeah
bro come on they used to sell nickel
bags at the park back then every
afternoon we make Doug Stanley make
[__] sun tea and we'd all meet there
at Gokey park that's what Mitch Hedberg
wrote the joke about I can't I'll never
be as good as my wall playing tennis
it's all that [__] I still remember
coming to my house with Mitch smoking
dope and him telling me about thinking
of moving to New York I don't know if
it's a good move and be going bro
there's nobody in New York like you
I don't belong in New York there's 20 of
me's there but you there
you go and he got to New York and he
blew up like a [__] that was a
hell of a [__] neighborhood
so wait what happened with the uh
Matthew yeah so Matthew McConaughey was
one of the celebrities in that
neighborhood and one day I'm sitting
upstairs with Ralph and he's like you
see this [__] out here I'm like
who is it is it Matthew McConaughey
Ralphie had a screen on his window you
could see out but you couldn't see him
and Ralphie would sit there in the
afternoon and go Matthew McConaughey
you sucked
I haven't seen 20 minutes and after a
while Matthew McConaughey would throw
his wrench down and go who the [__] is
saying that up there [__] you you got
the ball so Sammy Matthew McConaughey
you suck
[__] you and then the next day again and
then he would start with Matthew
McConaughey you owe me 750 for The
Wedding Singer whatever
[__] you how many movies have you done
but he couldn't see us but we could see
him it was a good fortune chamber for
like three months every time he went
back there Matthew McConaughey I'm not
listening to you [__] today
leave me the [__] alone every day we had
a war with him
and you've never connected with
McConaughey about this no until one day
I went to Ralphie's and McConaughey was
sitting on his no Ralphie went because
makana ain't threatened him how about I
come up there and beat y'all Ralph he's
like Matthew McConaughey hey you suck it
was like a broken record
oh [__] Ralphie's a Texas boy too yeah
they became friends yeah I go up there
one day he's on the couch sitting there
Smoking Buns I'm like what the [__] wait
they became homies they became like for
that day
oh
[Laughter]